- Hallo, guten Abend.
- Guten Abend.
- Schon mal die Karten.
- Danke schön.
- Bitte sehr.
Schon was zu trinken für Sie?
Ein Gläschen Wein zum Essen vielleicht?
- Ich hätte gerne einen Weißwein, ja.
- Möchten Sie einen Riesling,
der ist eher spritzig,
oder lieber einen Weißburgunder,
der ist ein bisschen milder, fruchtig?
- Dann nehme ich den Weißburgunder.
- Den Weißburgunder, gerne.
Und für Sie auch ein Glas Wein?
Rosé vielleicht zum Hauptgang?
- Nee, ich nehm lieber ein Bier.
- Ein Pils oder ein Kölsch?
- Ich hätt gern ein Kölsch.
- Ja? Gerne. Alles klar.
Einmal das Kölsch, bitte schön.
Da habe ich für Sie den Weißburgunder.
Sie können gerne mal
ein Schlückchen probieren.
- Danke.
- Bitte schön.
- Haben Sie schon entschieden,
was Sie essen möchten?
- Ja.
- Ja? Was dürfen wir Ihnen denn bringen?
- Für mich gerne die Burrata.
- Gerne.
- Die wird ohne Nüsse zubereitet, oder?
- Ja, also wir können …
… müssen das Dressing ändern,
weil Nussöl drin ist, aber das ist
kein Problem, das kriegen wir hin.
- Gerne!
- Gerne, für Sie?
- Für mich bitte die
Gurken-Joghurt-Millefeuille.
- Ja, gerne.
Bei Ihnen auch irgendwas,
worauf wir achten müssen?
Irgendwas, was Sie nicht vertragen?
- Nee.
- Nee, alles gut? Okay.
- Ich ess alles.
- Und im Hauptgang,
was darf ich Ihnen da mitbringen?
- Für mich gerne das Saint-Pierre-Filet.
- Den Saint-Pierre, gerne.
- Und ich hätt als Hauptgang
gerne den Kalbsrücken
mit Pfifferlingen und den Kalbsrücken
gerne rosa gebraten.
- Machen wir, gerne. Alles klar.
Einmal den Saint-Pierre für Sie.
- Danke sehr.
- Bitte schön.
Und der Kalbsrücken.
- Danke.
- Bitte schön.
Guten Appetit wünsche ich!
- Danke.